this is going to be a good week look I
put this here yeah you are everything
that I'm about artificial you're too
tall for the Vaser and you're never
going to die you have same size as my
head hey guys welcome to another episode
of the what is this exactly said
everyone subscribe to this channel oh
this is gonna be a great week and that's
getting kicked off with laurdiy on not
too deep this week if you do not know
laurdiy
you should because she is a very
adorable and also super savvy DIY on
youtube she has taught me that life gets
better when you actually invest in a
good quality glue gun and we had a
really wonderful conversation on the
podcast I learned the greatest gift
she's ever given someone was that she
gave her grandmother a new arm in honor
of laurdiy being on the podcast this
week I thought I would intro this
abbreviated podcast episode with a very
quick DIY I made this geode display case
I was in world market the other day and
I saw this almost exact thing on the
wall for $60 it had three geodes and I
realized I could make this myself so I
bought this shadow box from Michael and
weeks ago I'd actually bought a bunch of
geodes off of Amazon that you can smash
at home they're supposed to be for
children but they're definitely better
for adults and so I smashed some geodes
I picked my favorite ones and I have
glued them into the shadow box and there
you go I think in total this probably
cost me maybe 40 bucks
we're here with with large.i why learn
how do you pronounce your actual last
name I know everyone avoids it they're
like it's Lauren or you get REME it is
it's Rimac e reom aqui yeah it's got a
lot of ease and a lot of eyes in there
no ease before I all right there we go
and I thought for a second that your
last name was DIY and then I realized
that could never be but y'know you know
what though like I have a new identity
it's only laurdiy and what do you think
is the best gift you've ever given
someone because you seem because you're
crafty like are you someone that makes
gifts a lot yeah definitely I usually I
mean and they've advanced throughout the
years but I mean like my early years of
DIY gifting yeah where
pretty funny so my Nana my mom's mom had
broken her arm like right before
Christmas huh so I made her this like
hilarious paper mache arm oh my god it
was so good this don't have it made her
like a brand new arm as like net I got
you a new arm for Christmas because I
just broke it
oh man I had put like a hardly a tattoo
and it was like Papa like with the
banner like that kinda tastic it was so
and the arm is still kicking is my mom
broke her wrist not too long ago and my
Nana like from like the dust and cobwebs
of her attic brings out the paper mache
that's incredible so now it's this gift
that just travels through your family
when broken bones that how did you make
it um I think it was - paper towel rolls
as the base of paper mache and then just
newspaper that's so creative yeah I wish
my brain worked like that it's like
MacGyver of crafts it's pretty
incredible you like music I do what has
been the best concert experience that
you've had
she just went to uh this smaller hip-hop
guy Keith makes like really chill like
hip-hop electronic music uh-huh
blackberry his name is oh cool um so he
played like a super last minute like
24-hour let everyone know before like on
Twitter show the other day and I went to
that and there was like 50 people whoa
so when I was bought tickets for his
concert that's like next month I'm
actually in LA and so glad that I didn't
that's so cool I know nothing about
music and so I always have someone's
like I'm like black bear whoa that's way
cooler little I will ever be in my life
um do you have like a genre do you like
hip-hop and that sort of thing um okay
so I would go to eight tracks and put in
the keywords to get the playlist Isla
yeah uh it's still sex electro those the
keywords that get me the sex electro
whoa whoa those are gonna be my new
Pinterest keyword search terms it's
gonna be really great whoa what does
that even mean chill sex electro yeah
that's what I know I was like the
weekend yeah that we kind of fall into
there I got to learn more about music
I'm so bad just like jock jams again can
we get like a more updated jock jams
awesome that'd be really great
we're still making jock jams I hope so I
mean they make so much Kidz Bop barn is
spent
a stick and make sure you listen to the
full episode of not too deep on
soundcloud or iTunes the links are down
below and thank you for watching this
video you are appreciated don't forget
to subscribe
woah oh oh woah put it here wow you look
great
covered up by that subscription button I
don't know
Gio don't know yikes
hey any movies oh my gosh you don't know
music you know my boy what do you do
jeez you're seeing Krampus and the red
minute yeah that's my spectrum that's my
spectrum you know this podcast is to be
renamed my guests get upset with my lack
of cultural knowledge